i've been using the airpods max ever
since they launched and in this video i
will share everything that i found
within the last week
both the good and the bad and four
things that i wasn't expecting
that really surprised me in my first
impressions video i said that i had no
desire to buy these headphones
and if i didn't have this youtube
channel i wouldn't have
so i'll answer if i regret spending 600
bucks on a pair of headphones
after a week of using them and if you
should drop the cash
if you're on the fence trying to decide
if it's worth spending the money
let's start out with something that
probably matters the most
and what people haven't really talked
that much about comfort
when i first put these on i was shocked
by how little i felt
the headband most headbands use a piece
of plastic with some padding added to
make the headband feel softer on your
head with every pair of headphones i've
used as soon as i put them on i feel
that headband putting pressure on my
head
and then after a few minutes i start to
forget about that as i concentrate on my
music
podcast or video editing and then
depending on the headphones somewhere
between 30 minutes to 2 hours of using
him
that pressure really starts to build up
and gets strong enough that i could no
longer ignore it
and it becomes exponentially more
annoying and
almost painful as i keep wearing them
well the longest i've worn the airpods
max
is about three and a half hours so far
and i still
barely feel the headband it's incredible
and now it makes sense why apple chose
to use such an
unconventional headband design now not
everything is perfect
comfort wise where you really feel the
earpods max are the ear cups
they definitely have more clamping
pressure than most of the headphones
that i own
and i think this is for two reasons
first is to provide a really good seal
for the active noise cancellation
which we'll talk about in just a bit and
second
to hold all the extra weight which these
things weigh
about 50 more than its biggest
competitors
on your head without shifting down too
much now with that extra weight i was
thinking that they would be weighing
down
on my head but when you're sitting you
don't really notice it which is great
but if you want to walk around with your
headphones you definitely feel that
weight because they slightly bounce up
and down as you step
probably because of the springy stretchy
fabric headband
which is a bit annoying and because of
that you
definitely do not want to run with these
things on now the clamping pressure
is harder to ignore than i expected sure
if i'm really into my music i can forget
about it for a little bit but it doesn't
really disappear
like my audio technicas do because you
always
feel it there but on the plus side
because the ear cups are comically
large there's a ton of room for even my
larger ears
so pressure is mainly on the head not on
the ears themselves but surprisingly
after over three hours
i don't feel any more pressure than i
did at the start
where my m50 is due at least on the ears
themselves
and along with that i was surprised that
my ears don't get hot
at all like they do with those or the
sonys now i haven't used them for a full
eight to ten hour day just yet and
honestly i've actually
never done that with any headphones
because of comfort but i will and i will
get back to you guys on that
in my full detailed review that will
also cover a ton of battery life
tests both with and without active noise
cancellation
and talking about battery drain if
you're not using
this smart case if you want to see that
go ahead and click that subscribe button
down below
and with that you can help us try to
reach 550k
subs before the end of the year before i
get into sound quality let me quickly
cover a few random things
first off the quality of the microphones
is shockingly good and not only in the
way that you would expect
let's start out by taking a listen to
how it compares to the sony xm4s
this is the microphone quality of the
sony xm4s in
a fairly noisy room and this is the
microphone quality of the airpods max in
a fairly noisy environment this is the
microphone quality
of the sony xm4s in a really quiet room
this is the microphone quality of the
airpods max in a really quiet room
not only do the microphones sound very
clear they sound almost identical
whether you're in a loud room or in a
quiet room
the airpods pros also sound good but
when there's a lot of noise like if
you're driving in a car
it gets much tougher to hear you i wore
these in my truck a few times and my
wife had no
issues hearing me but here's what
surprised me even more
i was using them early this morning and
my wife called me
i picked up and i was pretty much
whispering to her since my kids were
sleeping
but she heard me perfectly fine it's in
these tough cases where i
typically switch over to my phone
instead of using my earpod pros
because it starts to get tough to hear
but the microphones that are in here
which is actually three mics that pick
up your voice are amazing and i think
that's because we have
the extra mics with one dedicated
microphone unit
and really good processing next i love
the controls that apple went with
not only do they work really well but
they feel so nice to use
apple is able to perfectly balance
having enough pressure needed not to
click them
accidentally when you're putting them on
or if you're adjusting them but also
not putting enough pressure down when
you press to shift the headphones down
if you're switching modes or
you know adjusting and skipping tracks
and with that
they do not feel mushy at all or too
springy and even though we technically
only have two buttons you still have
access to everything that you need
and if you want to add the off mode to
the active noise cancellation toggle
you can do that in the settings and then
lastly the digital crown is just
amazing to quickly and precisely adjust
volume
it is vastly superior to having a touch
surface
or having multiple buttons that you have
to keep clicking to adjust your volume
next let's talk about bluetooth apple
advertises dual 10 core h1 chips
one in each ear cup and it's interesting
because the airpod pros
also have the same dual h1 chips but
they didn't make it
as big of a deal because of that you
would think that the bluetooth
performance would be the same
but it's not at first i thought it was
just updated firmware but testing both
side by side
there's definitely some differences in
the last week the airpods max have never
let me down
switching between devices especially
when selecting them
on my mac they connect quicker and more
reliably
where at times the airpods pros won't
connect
or i won't hear anything and then i
would have to reconnect along with that
i had my iphone 12 mini charging in my
kitchen and i went to take out the trash
on the other side of the house
and they did not cut out where's my
airpod pros typically do
so maybe the bluetooth just has more
power going to it for a stronger signal
but who knows guess we might as well
talk about the case now
and yeah it sucks i do understand why
apple went with this
style of case since it keeps the
headphones super slim and you don't have
to adjust the headband
to get it to fit into the case like you
do with others but it doesn't completely
protect the ear cups
and the magnets for the flap sometimes
it's just not that strong when i'm
putting them
in and closing it i understand that they
want to make everything simple and they
want these to match the other airpods
where you just put them in the case to
turn them off
and then you pull them out to turn them
on but they should have included
some way to manually shut these off i
still think that they could with the
firmware update
possibly allowing you to press down this
button for five seconds to manually shut
them off
so hopefully they end up doing that and
now let's talk about
the active noise cancellation and it is
out of this world beating out the best
bose and sony headphones
with that i also didn't find the
constant pressure
of the anc working to cancel out noise
to be an issue when i was listening to
music or podcasts
but when i used them for about a half
hour just to block out noise
the pressure definitely started to build
up and
kind of get to me and this can
definitely be an issue for some people
now the only thing that makes sense to
me
is if the noise cancellation strength
gets turned down
as the volume of your content goes up
either way
i wish apple gave us a way to adjust the
strength of noise cancellation like a
lot of the competitors do even if it was
buried somewhere deep in the bluetooth
settings because in those times say if
you're on an airplane and you're just
trying to sleep you want to shut off
your music
and get rid of some of that noise you
either get
full crazy active noise cancellation or
just the ability to shut
it off nothing really in between and now
let's talk about sound quality and it is
both good
and bad it's good because these things
live up to their price tag both in
separation of instruments
clarity and much more importantly than i
expected
soundstage i'll be expanding this much
more in the full review
but at this point i kept wanting to
listen to
a bunch of old songs that i loved to see
if i noticed any sounds that i haven't
heard before
and that did happen now sure they might
their price bracket but with cheaper
materials not using aluminum and
stainless
and of course without any of the extra
features
like batteries and electronics
processors microphones all of that stuff
that's needed
for bluetooth the amplification all of
that but to be honest
i don't really want to hear those
headphones because i really appreciate
having all the extra conveniences of
these being bluetooth
and all the software features on ios
things like that that is why
i use my earpod pros way more than
regular headphones
even if they sounded worse now the bad
part about sound quality
is that they make all of my other
headphones sound
much worse than they did before and
because of that i want to bring these
things with me
everywhere like i do with the airpod
pros but of course i can't because they
are
very large and heavy and much more of a
pain to take with me
the only other negative and i want to
give you guys this right now before my
full review
is that i wish they did get louder with
certain songs or
sources most of the time they are great
but for quiet tracks i want a bit more
since unfortunately i love listening to
loud music
which isn't always good i know it's not
good obviously my tinnitus
proves that but i just wish we can crank
it up a bit more in those times that you
need it overall
after a week of use i don't regret
spending 600
on these headphones as long as i keep
using them instead of using my airpod
pros
now if i didn't try them out and i
didn't hear all the differences
i probably would be regretting it but
once you get to actually try these and
you spend some time with them
you understand why they are priced at
this point
and i know for a lot of us that don't
buy expensive headphones
it just seems like crazy to spend that
much and then for audio files these seem
like very cheap headphones for them so
of course
price wise that is really subjective
depending on how much you've spent in
the past
and kind of what you're looking for as
far as sound quality now for those of
you guys that are on the fence
trying to decide if you should spend the
money on these
i think that if you're on the fence that
means that you are willing to spend
that amount already and in that case i
do not think you'll be disappointed
uh the sound quality is fantastic the
microphones are awesome
just the overall experience with these
and how they blend into
the ios ecosystem that part of it is
fantastic as well
so i would say if you're considering it
yes go ahead and pick these up now for
me personally i know that i'm going to
use these for many years to come
and the sound quality the software and
even the gaming experience
which yes i will cover in my full review
is fantastic
thank you guys for watching click that
circle above if you guys want to see
that video and you can also help us
reach 550k subs before the end of the
year
and go ahead and check out one of those
great comparisons right over there
if you haven't seen them already it's
been max and i'll catch you
in the next video